ma collègue Coline Brulin vient de vous
demander une suspension de séance je
crois que ça serait normal de nous
l'accorder parce que l'amendement de
Monsieur Retailleau devait venir hier
soir il n'est pas arrivé il venait il
devait venir ce matin il n'est toujours
pas là et maintenant mais je suis
Retailleau nous propose donc de discuter
en catimini ce soir de cet amendement et
donc ce n'est pas possible nous vous le
disons depuis le début nous ne faisons
pas d'obstruction nous défendons pieds à
pied la réforme des retraites
c'est vous qui êtes l'obstruction
l'obstruction au peuple l'obstruction
aux gens qui défilent dans la rue et qui
combattent votre réforme et c'est pour
ça que cette nuit vous nous avez fait
voter en catimini l'article 7 parce que
vous êtes vous avez honte finalement de
ce que vous êtes en train de faire alors
on a on a eu le tour Monsieur
nos amendements finalement n'ont pas
n'ont pas été la fois passée ils n'ont
pas ils ne sont pas venus en commission
des affaires sociales c'était un
simulacre démocratie alors nous
demandons de réunir la commission des
affaires sociales que Monsieur
Retailleau puisse déposer son amendement
comme c'était prévu ce matin dans
l'ordre du jour que nous puissions
réunir la commission des affaires
sociales pour discuter de nos
sous-amendements
[Musique]